foreign
how do I support a friend who cheated on
her husband without enabling her
decision it's not by your hand but in
your lap you had a really close friend
who did a thing and then it dragged you
along through the deception and the
dishonesty and if I'm you I'm not going
along on that ride
what's up what's up this is John with
the Dr John deloney show the greatest
show that has ever existed
on the internet on the podcast when it
comes to mental health and marriage and
relationships and whatever else is going
on in your life if you want to be on the
show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 and we'd love to have you
on the show
um
and if you don't have access to a phone
go to johndalene.com ask and if you
don't have access to a phone you should
probably get one because it's the 21st
century okay so Kelly's out today
and Jenna you're running the show yes
how's it feel I feel a lot of power yeah
do you I do can we just say just
starting the show out you've been so
much Kinder in my headphones than Kelly
generally is so that's fantastic I think
wow thank you for that we'll see if that
changes I'm fairly certain that it will
let's go to Samantha out in Philadelphia
Samantha what are you doing
I'm just waiting to talk to you John
awesome so being a caller is it weird
listening to all the shenanigans behind
the scenes or is it exactly what you
thought it was going to be
um is what I thought it was going to be
but it's still
very cool uh okay so what's up what's
going on
um so I'll go straight to my question
um my question is how do I support a
friend who cheated on her husband
without enabling her decision
tell me more
okay so it's a really close friend like
we grew up together super close and she
cheated on her husband and I guess a
little more that I found out since I put
the call question in is that she hasn't
told the husband the extent to her
cheating so there's that I know you
always say Secrets destroy things but
it's not my secret to tell so I'm
struggling with a how to support her and
B like we hang out with them all the
time so it's weird yes Secrets destroyed
and so does sleeping with your husband's
friend right so both of those things
both those things hurt marriage oh man
okay so
how did how did she how did she tell you
how did this come to you
um so she she made like a cryptic
Facebook post a little while back in
December at the end of the end of the
year and I like touched base there to
see like how things were going it kind
of just like came out as word vomit and
so it was like this hour-long phone call
and then after we get through it all
like her husband found the text messages
thought it was just emotional and then
as we're ending the phone call she goes
oh I actually slept with him too and I
was like oh
I didn't know what to say
so what has happened since then how did
you find out that she hasn't told her
husband yet yeah so
awesome too unless it like comes up in
marriage counseling which he doesn't
want to go to he's just kind of rug
sweeping the situation
like wants to move past it so it's like
obviously never gonna come up if he
never goes to therapy and she never says
anything
um
So when you say enabling what do you
mean by that
um so I want to support her obviously
like she's my best friend but also like
there she says these like weird things
to kind of justify her cheating and
obviously I'm a big time listener so
like no one else makes you make the
choices you decide like you decide that
and I don't know how to like get that
through her head that no matter what her
husband did to her like it's not his
fault
so
I've had moments in my life when I have
close friends
and they do something
they
um violate my trust in a way
that makes me wonder
if you can do that in this situation
what would you do with my trust
what would you do with our relationship
and the moment and this is this is just
me the moment I go there
often there's a turning point in that
relationship from that point forward
it's different now
and
just personally speaking
um I think I've told this on on the show
before and if I haven't if I have um I
guess it's worth repeating
um one time I was sitting down with a
group of guys and I had moved to a new
city and my wife had was finishing up
her dissertation research so she was
gonna move six months later and so we
were just gonna hang out on the weekends
it was about three hours away from each
other so after about two months I was
hanging out with this group of guys and
they had been really kind and welcomed
me in and several of them I'm still
super close to to this day and we were
all making jokes and just being stupid
guys sitting around a table and I said
they said hey do you need anything and I
was like well man I'm super lonely if
anyone knows of any girlfriends here in
this new city totally kidding and one
guy his name's Kevin
one of my closest friends said
um hey you don't know us that well and
so just so we're super clear
if you ever cheat on your wife you
better hope to God she finds you before
we do
and it was a very like this is who we
are and this is how we're gonna roll
now I know some of the people in that
group have have they've walked through
infidelity with each other they've
walked through all kinds of crazy stuff
together
the difference is and and again
everyone's got their own opinions on
this this is just me I have worked in
student conduct long enough I've sat
with people who have done stupid things
and had bad moments and had bad weekends
I've had bad months right where they
just did things that were so out of
character
and so I often tell people I don't think
character is the initial incident
I think character is who you are after
you do something
yeah destructive right and so she's
she's she hooks up with somebody okay
that happens in my world with dealing
with people who are married that happens
it happens it happens
you're getting to see in real time who
she is on the back end of doing
something that could potentially be
devastating to somebody that she says
she loves
and that is I'm gonna lie I'm gonna hide
it I'm gonna bury it and I'm gonna hand
it to my friend to Carrie
and bring her drag her through all this
see what I'm saying and so for me the
enabling is is not about the marriage
thing you can't you can no more do
anything about that
unless you just felt so compelled I've
got a few friends that their wives are
basically equally as close and I would
say hey we're gonna have this
conversation and I'll do it with you but
I'm not holding the secret for you but
that's just very very few the rest of
them man I mean that's
but I'm not gonna hang out with you I'm
going to opt out of this relationship
right not because you did a thing one
time not because you did a thing over a
period of a few months or whatever
it's because you showed your true colors
your true character on the back end of
this mistake and you've continued to
blame other people you've continued to
pass the buck you've continued to lie
about it does that make sense
yeah I know that that hits hard but it's
true and so
um the you've heard me say this it's not
by your hand but in your lap you had a
really close friend who did a thing and
then it's dragged you along through the
deception and the dishonesty and if I'm
you I'm not going along on that ride
yeah and I think that may it can be as
easy as I'm just not going to return
your text anymore or calls anymore
or it can be as direct and honest as
taking her to coffee and saying hey I I
can't be a part of this because I feel
like I'm getting dragged through it
because I know something when we sit
down as a fan as a couple you know we're
all sitting down I know something he
doesn't know and I can't I can't be a
part of that I can't
and she's gonna call you every name in
the book and blah that's cool
but as far as I'm concerned she didn't
get a photo anymore
yeah
that's kind of how I've been feeling
like I think about it you know and my
husband I talk about it and we're just
like it's just awkward like we just hang
out with them and it's just awkward
super awkward yeah for real it's awkward
so
um what is that you know her and you
know how she would hear things
um
there's people in my life who I love
that we've been places and I'd say hey
give me your keys I'm driving home
and I know I'm gonna have to go ask this
guy for his keys it's gonna be a fight
no bro I'm flying up he's not driving
you're not driving home and then there's
others that are more than happy to hand
the keys over how is this conversation
gonna go
um it'll be a fight okay
yeah
everyone else is just kind of like
either a doesn't know the full
information so they're like he's being
irrational about everything like her
husband or like
be like just cuddling her and just being
like it's okay get through it so I don't
think anyone has really like had the I
don't want to say courage because I
don't think it's the courageous thing
it's just like been truthful and
straightforward with her hmm
I think the truth and
straightforwardness has to be about you
though
yeah yeah otherwise it becomes you
throwing grenades at somebody and I just
I'm not participating in that very often
occasionally I'll say hey you're you've
heard the show enough like occasionally
very if you go back and listen to it
carefully it's rare that I say this is a
terrible person
usually I'm an OG listener so okay so
I've never really heard you say that
it's rare that I I find that like you're
an awful human and you don't deserve to
be around usually it's people have
because of particular Pathways they've
ended up in a place that nobody wants to
be in and they don't know how to get out
and that happens
um
this one's a mess I I just I I I I would
sit down and say I can't participate in
this anymore this makes it about you I'm
uncomfortable
sitting down at a table with your
husband and you and acting like
everything's normal because it's not
everything's in ashes and y'all just
playing and so I don't want to
participate in this and not make it
about you cheated and you're this and
you're a liar I wouldn't go that route
make it about you and then walk away
yeah short sweet and to the point which
is so hard I know I know that's so hard
but it's
honestly knowing her
person will have her
one of my core core um
core beliefs is or core actions I guess
is I only speak to be heard I don't
speak to just who so I can have said
something right I get a lot of heat on
the internets for not responding to
every thing that goes on in the world
and
um if things are super volatile and
political and nonsensical I'm not gonna
be heard they just people just want to
find out what team I'm on and so for
this I'm going to speak in a way that
can be heard and that is I'm choosing to
not be around you right now
and I think it's also fair to say I love
you and I will walk through hell with
you
if you're willing to walk through hell
but if you're willing if you're just
gonna try to avoid the whole thing I'm
not I'm not taking that route with you
I really like that is that cool
I really appreciate that sorry that
happened to you man it's such a bummer
man we want our friends who especially
our Rider dies to have our same values
and not do stupid things and when they
do do stupid things to come to us and
say hey walk with me through
the reconciliation through this stupid
thing or walk with me through the next
chapter and phase of My Life
um
and I've got close friends that I love
and I'll say what you're doing is really
stupid you can come stay at my house and
uh your wife can come stay at my house
or your ex could come stay at my house
you're welcome here but I'm telling you
I think what you're doing is dumb
because you asked me
um and so I'm really honest with folks
but
sorry I wish it was a great outcome here
I don't see it being super great
it may be in the long term though it may
be that your words and your honesty and
your directness and your friendship and
the way you love your friend and holder
accountable
in this wacky accountable free world we
live in now might be
somebody ripping back the curtains in
the shades and letting the light in that
she really needs thank you for loving
her we'll be right back
I've got a word from our sponsor better
help listen I've been on both ends of
therapy in my life I've gotten it myself
and I've walked people through it and
I've seen the benefits from both sides
when someone owns their past and the
cracks in their armor but here's the
deal Getting to Know Yourself is not a
one-time event acknowledging the stories
that make you who you are can be a
lifelong process and talking through
things with the right sounding board
empowers you to change your future and
be the best version of yourself so if
you're thinking about starting therapy I
recommend better help better help
connect you with a licensed therapist
who can walk with you on that journey of
self-discovery and it's a hundred
percent online and it's designed to be
convenient flexible and work for your
schedule just fill out a quick
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and if it's not the
right fit you can switch therapists at
any time for no additional charge visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com
all right we're back let's do uh a
lightning round cue the uh
pervy hip thrusting music
you don't like that
no it that's the music that Kelly Gets
Dressed to every morning and it's just
uncomfortable
tattoos she tells us sometimes she calls
when she's brushing her teeth and that
music is just blaring in the background
she wants to talk about a show segment
or something it's super awkward so on
brand for her all right lightning round
let's do it yes all right we're doing
lightning round anxiety and depression
it's gonna be so fun
I just imagine you telling your husband
like we are going to clean the house
it's gonna be so fun yes we're gonna
have the we're gonna smile while we do
it we're gonna clean the roof off it's
gonna be great so far yeah okay go ahead
go for it first question you often hear
of people being diagnosed with anxiety
and depression together why are the two
so often connected so when something's
diagnosed together it's called comorbid
um I guess that means you
die again maybe that's what that means
not really not comorbid
um but it
anxiety and depression are on the same
trend line and so you and I may have
different genetics and different life
experiences that lead us to this moment
and a bear runs in that door and your
body shuts off and it's going to stay
shut off for a while and my body's gonna
get up and spin up and get ready to rock
and roll often the difference between
the two is not the particular stressor
it's just how our bodies are responding
and in in some brain scans studies it
shows that the very similar brain
mechanisms are are driving both of those
all I have to say is
um they're on the same trend line and if
you're anxious long enough long enough
long enough your body will shut the
system down and um and sometimes it
works vice versa I'll have to say is
that's why perfect is that helpful yeah
I was going to say thank you for
bringing up my deathly fear of bears so
you have that oh yeah
I've had nightmares they just chase me
I'm not going to see cocaine there let
me just say that all right next next
question we're moving on what is the
difference between a panic attack and an
anxiety attack
um
not a lot
um panic I think that's again I think
that's kind of Internet splitting panic
attacks usually don't have a trigger
they just show up so we'll be walking on
the street and all of a sudden I'll get
real short of breath my heart will be
either thousand miles an hour and I'll
double over and I don't I my brain
starts I start spinning with all these
negative thoughts anxiety attack is
usually I got a test I got a test I got
a test I got a test and it slowly wears
you down the reason I don't care so much
about which one it is is the
physiological mechanisms are usually
pretty similar
your body your heart starts beating
really fat your body is ready to go to
war right or it's ready to get the heck
out of there and so
um yeah it's one of those things that if
you're sitting there and someone you
love can't breathe and they're
hyperventilating and they're having all
these catastrophic thoughts and you're
trying to figure out well is this a
panic attack or an anxiety it's not
helpful not helpful right right
um okay so are there any symptoms of an
anxiety attack that I can pinpoint
before it happens
sure anxiety attack I mean just using
the internet literature which is those
that wasn't very good
there's not never mind
um my science friends will just roll
their eyes what I just said and um so
save your question again I'm sorry I got
lost
I don't have a lot of friends
are there any symptoms of an anxiety
attack I can pinpoint before it happens
uh I mean if you if if you start
ruminating pretty hard and you start
spitting yourself up and the thoughts
you are having begin your heart starts
racing on you and
um
you started having real shallows of
breath and you will feel like I need to
go for a walk but I can't go for a walk
that's you feel it starting to come on
um and again that's so human that's so
person specific right so it's I I don't
want someone being like I think I'm
having a panic attack I think I'm having
anxiety attack because you can sure talk
your way into one right
um I think getting Upstream as soon as
you start having those ruminating
thoughts that's when you can build in
some I'm gonna stop this conversation
right now or I've talked about on the
show I'll be walking through my living
room and I'll just be like no stop or
I'll be in the shower and my wife will
hear me yell out no and that's just me
I'm stopping a conversation a fight that
I'm having because I don't want to end
up down down river that way right
um does alcohol or caffeine cause
anxiety
oh that's a great question
um I tend to think caffeine mimics
the symptomology of I mean symptoms of
anxiety and so uh if I have way way too
much caffeine I start my brain starts
spinning a little faster my heart rate
is beating my I'm kind of clinched up a
little bit and then my body's like oh
we're supposed to be anxious right and
it will it will follow suit
um alcohol has some Gaba effects I don't
get all that stuff but yes there's a
reason why
um I think on a limke says it talks
about it best about the teeter-totter
and if you depress
neurochemicals on one side your brain
will respond by Smashing the other side
of the teeter-totter and so if you have
a depressant effect and you shut some of
the system down it will come back in
full force on the other side so yes it
can there's a reason why you wake up in
the morning after you've had too many
drinks the night before and you have
that anxious feeling what I say what did
I say did they think I was crazy what
did I and who did I kiss like all that I
mean that's a natural I don't get all
the the Neuroscience of it but yes
awesome and I also think this I also
think in the long term alcohol has uh
it messes with sleep and it screws up
your REM sleep and over time a body
deprived of REM sleep will begin to try
to get your attention and let you know
things are not well at home and it'll
start rattling so I think there's a
long-term effect there too yeah what are
the best things to do when having an
anxiety attack drink just kidding don't
do that
um the the so this happened in a parking
lot I pulled up and there was a bunch of
people leaning into a car and I was like
what is happening over there and
um I walked over and realized it's the
somebody yelled someone's having an
anxiety attacks I was having a panic
attack and so I cleared everybody out of
the way and then I reached in and said
will you take my hand and she did and I
said would you be willing to walk with
me so she got out of the car and I
literally put her hand on my chest and
we went for a walk and so I held skin to
skin contact here I let her feel my
heartbeat literally and we walked around
the parking lot and I had her look at
things like tell me what's there she's
like there's grass I'm like yes where's
the leaves and she's like there's one
there's one and all I was trying to do
was bring her body into the right now
and um so skin to skin contact heartbeat
like
um just getting your body from some
future Terror to you're here right now
you're okay and it's pretty quick yeah
I've I've kind of dealt with that before
where I find it helpful to do like the
54321 method where it's like five things
that I can see just to kind of like get
my mind off four things that I can hear
three things I can feel two things I can
smell never heard that one thing I can
taste kind of like to get your senses to
like start focusing on something else
and by the end of it my breathing's calm
down my heart rate's down and I just
find it so helpful I like that
um back when I was doing death
notifications or I I would show up to
somebody's house and there was Madness
um we used to just go for walks and it
was not be strange for me to be holding
hands with a 55 year old man walking
down the street
and all we're doing is just counting
cracks in the sidewalk like let's count
one two and let's count the trees and so
we're just coming back to humanity here
because what he just saw
um his life will never be the same yeah
right yeah
um next question you say anxiety is like
a smoke alarm can you explain that uh
yeah in our culture we've turned anxiety
into a disease or into a genetic
disorder or into some sort of illness
that um comes upon you like the flu or
like coverage like you something you
catch and so when people say the words
like I have anxiety it's either talking
like it's an identity like this is who I
am now I'm just an anxious person who
experiences the world in this way or I
have a thing that I caught I've got a
thing now and um I reject both of those
across I mean object all that across the
board all anxiety is is your body trying
to get your attention it's just trying
to let you know generally speaking you
haven't been taking care of your body
um like me too much caffeine 300 400
milligrams of caffeine a day my body's
gonna start rattling after a while
um and then I'm not sleeping and then so
on and so forth I'm disconnected your
body's found itself without a tribe and
by the way you can be have great work
mates you can be married and happy and
you can be profoundly and deeply alone
and so it is
um when your body detects you don't have
a tribe that you are all alone or if
you're not safe if you're in an abusive
relationship you don't have autonomy you
don't get to make decisions for your
life the bank does your your boss does
things like that
awesome okay next one here's where
that's important if you feel anxious if
you rush to stop the anxiousness
man that
that's like getting shot and rushing to
just cover up the hole in your body
instead of trying to figure out where is
bullets coming from right who's shooting
and why and so
when you feel anxious man what a gift
your body to step back at least an inch
and just say what are you trying to
protect me from if we all just asked
ourselves that question man we'd have a
radically different world right yeah my
husband's anxiety can lead to him
lashing out at me how can I help him at
these times I I reject that sentiment
um nobody's anything makes them do
anything or very very rarely
your husband is choosing to respond to
those alarms by swinging and so what you
can do is you can't make him do or do
anything you can control you and so if
your husband gets anxious and then
lashes out you can say I will not be in
a home where I feel unsafe
so when you get anxious and you lash out
I am taking that behavior as as a
language and the language you are giving
me is I don't want you here anymore
and so I will leave I will not be in a
place where someone's going to talk to
me that way treat me like that way and
if you have anxiety and your body's
impulse is to lash out right fight or
flight I'm gonna fight
um when I get anxious my body's response
is to run and that's not helpful when I
have two little kids and I have a wife
at home and I've got work and all that
kind of stuff so when you find that your
body has an Impulse when it gets anxious
it's my responsibility
to deal with anxiety to deal with that
impulse and to continue to treat people
with dignity and respect including
myself that's on me I have to
do the things that I know I need to do
to get well sometimes let's go sit with
a counselor sometimes let's go talk to a
medical doctor psychiatrist whatever
that looks like that's my responsibility
not
um somebody else's yep that's good
um is there such a thing as situational
anxiety like before a job interview
going out of town some have flying
I mean we're getting into semantics here
I just call that stress and yes there's
tons of stress and stress is really good
for you this morning
um I was lifting weights and if I had
lifted weights with no weight on the bar
that would not have done my body any
good so I put weight on the bar so it
would stress my body out so that my body
can respond to that stress in an
appropriate way similarly like if you've
got a job interview I want your body
needs to have some stress man it's a big
deal don't screw this up you're not
gonna get that job right you need to
prepare you need to shower
um I don't know I was gonna say bathe
bathe and shower whatever you need to do
um get some sit down with some people
and go over your interview answers
whatever so stress can push us to do
good things
um so that that's a situational anxiety
I mean now I mean
I just call that stress
awesome okay last question is anxiety
ever beneficial
yes
um good grief Almighty who wrote the
what's there's a book called good
anxiety
um who wrote that
can't believe I disliked Yeah Wendy
Suzuki yeah good grief I can't believe I
lost her name
um
she I mean she really maintains what I
just said that when your alarm systems
are going off they're actually that's a
good thing I would say my uh smoke alarm
in my house is a good thing she would
say when your body's trying to get your
attention and you go exercise then it's
done good for you and so you can reframe
it
um I also
I mean anxiety is such a catch-all word
nowadays for anything that makes us go
we all say I got anxiety not really when
I had clinical anxiety there was nothing
good about it it burned a hole through
me um and it burned a hole through my
relationships and I did not respond well
to it so actually it didn't burn whole
through my relationships I did and so
there wasn't a lot good with it
um in retrospect as I began to get well
I begin to see that I'd created a world
that wasn't inhabitable for me or for my
family and so I guess it was good in
that way but man I wish my body had done
it another way but to be honest it it
probably was trying to get my attention
for a long time and um
it just hadn't been able to do it so it
finally started shutting the thing down
well that was I don't know I mean you've
experienced it have you ever felt it to
be good
um
I don't
I don't maybe in some situations where
I'm like oh my gosh if I wasn't feeling
anxiety I'm like maybe there's something
wrong with me that I'm not feeling
anxious about this thing
um like you said like for job interviews
like the stress like before of like if
I'm not feeling anxious and like excited
and ready
there's something wrong with me gotcha
so I think that's the only way that I
could see it as beneficial in my mind
but gotcha
yeah I I don't know
here's what I don't like about the
internet culture we're in now is there's
going to be someone who's got anxiety
who's doubled over with it and I don't
want their husband being like it's good
for you and that's terrible and on the
other side I don't want somebody who's
stressed out about something
who thinks they've and this is the world
we got where people have just regular
stress life is stressful life's hard and
everyone runs to
do away with the discomfort and they
label it some sort of Diagnostic and or
they now we've got what was that one we
had the other day that was uh
high functioning anxiety I was just
making up crap now like
like when you start labeling everything
with a diagnostic and to try to do away
with any sort of discomfort man you do
with away with any sort of growth any
way of getting from point A to point B
and we just want to stay in atrophy and
I I I don't know so I I don't like the
question just because it's it can be
weaponized either way and I think stress
is usually good until there's too much
of it or it becomes a way of life and I
think anxiety can get your attention in
a positive way and it can also vary so
um I don't say it's good or bad I think
it just is I think how we respond to it
is really what determines whether it's
good or bad
awesome well I had fun that's over
you're so ridiculous well I had a great
time great time all right cool that was
it that was uh are you gonna take us out
with this some more jamming Tunes I mean
I can I think the world needs some more
of this
all right we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here
I fell through a glitch in The Matrix
this is my job I get to have this show
do this show walk alongside each one of
you as a career this is what I do and I
have a blast doing it and me and the
team were so thankful for all of you for
being a part of our show whether you're
one of the original 17 or you're one of
the millions that's come since then we
are so grateful for you and we want to
put together the best possible show that
we can so if you're one of The Originals
or if you're brand new we want your
feedback tell us what you love about the
show what you hate about the show would
you like to see more of what you like to
hear more of and what you want us to
never do again you can email us at
askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's ask
John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right we are back uh no disturbing
music let's go to Angela in Dayton Ohio
what's up Angela
hey what's bacon nothing
um my hips were after those Tunes but
then they they've slowed down what's up
and these Hips Don't Lie by the way
Angela what's up
they never do they never do
I'm I'm in a situation
where they have an expectation
I need to help pay for
bills for my parents
and um I am not in a financial situation
where I can help with things like that
the way my brother can okay
and um
when when they don't get the answer that
they want
um they use a lot of uh bullying tactics
on me
why do you let them do that
that's a good question
um I I took a break for my family about
15-20 minutes 20-year breaks from them
and it was the most piece I had in my
life and the highest success I've had in
my life
why'd you come back into this mess
yeah so
um my grandfather was on his deathbed
and
um my dad was having a lot of health
issues
and they were they were kind of giving
off of five like they've had a change of
heart
and things were better for you know like
six months I was laid right back down
crap Mountain all over again
so what has kept you from going back to
the thing that kept you safe and saying
the last time
I think
um back then I had my son and all this
was happening in front of my son and for
some reason
I've been similar to identify it because
I don't have a child reacting to the
things that they are saying to me
can I give you another alternative
yes please you care about your child's
wellness and
um safety more than yours
why is that
why aren't you worthy of of being well
I don't know
I think just because I grew up with it
that there you go
yeah
and the system pulls us back in like a
vacuum cleaner and then we find
ourselves cycled out and we can breathe
again and we create our own world and
then somebody gets sick and we head back
in
um you may be like me I I remember
um at one of my jobs I mean I was
responsible for tens and tens and tens
and tens of millions of dollars an
expense in Revenue accounts hundreds of
people reported up through me it was a
big job
and then I would go home for the
holidays
and I instantly was middle child again
and I was about 14.
it's just instant you know what I mean
it just happens
I can relate to that because I'll go out
into the world and be a happy
functioning person at my job and around
my friends and then once I get around my
family I turn into
um an eight-year-old child that's been
verbally attacked and kicked around
that's right all over again
and when you show up their bodies
suddenly have an outlet that they don't
normally have which is to go back to the
way things were
and so
um
the hard part is at some point you
either have to say I'm gonna give up the
fantasy that this all works out in the
end because it doesn't
I don't say it doesn't it probably does
not I think that's where I'm at right
now
if you're there there's just gonna be
some deep grief
you're gonna have to spend some time
just being really sad
and being angry
because mom and dads aren't supposed to
treat you like that brothers and sisters
aren't supposed to treat you like that
right and if we're honest you've
probably contributed some and they would
be like well if she had just got her
crap together then all it just turns
into this weird dance
it's a sick dance
and when you're dancing with somebody
and they're leading you too aggressively
or they keep stepping on your toes you
can try to coach them while the music's
playing sometimes that works
well
um I was born with autoimmune disorders
and
um muscular issues that um
has I was just I was just always treated
like a burden of the family in place I
was I don't think I was ever going to be
in a position
um with my family to have the same
values that my brother does okay
and at some point you've got to make a
decision am I going to be in this or I'm
going to be out of this
and you might say I can't contribute all
the money you are expecting that you're
billing me for basically
um but I do want to honor my parents and
so I can contribute this
and I will con continue to contribute
this in this way
and I I tried that well I mean it's it's
not a matter of try he doesn't get a
vote
right you're gonna vote and so if he
won't take this or I demand this or I
demand that ah whatever
like I'm not gonna take your call about
that
right and that's that's actually what I
did good good for you for protecting
yourself here's the thing they don't
doesn't sound like they have like
usually this gets messy when there's a
huge inheritance or something and
somebody's trying to preserve they
they're going to put up with 10 years of
being bullied and kicked around by an
idiot brother or sister
in order to be a part of the inheritance
it doesn't sound like you have anything
to worry about there
no yeah
so at some point you write the letter
that you're probably not going to send
that is I'm sorry for the for the whole
course of my life you'll have I've been
a burden to you
I'm not a burden to me and I'm not a
burden to those that love and care about
me
right and so I'm out
I wish you all the best
and you will probably
your guts will feel like they fall out
yeah
because the reality of that hitting is
gonna
it's gonna be like a ton of bricks
Fair
yeah I
I tried
um holding a song for three years in
this situation and it's
um it just feels like
uh Michelle was who I used to be when
I'm around them
the world needs Angela to step up and be
fully Angela
all right will you commit to doing that
absolutely okay
and I don't say that lightly because I
know what that costs you
right it's gonna cost you holidays by
yourself
it's gonna cost you
um
updates it's gonna cost you all kinds of
stuff
okay it might give you back your soul
right
God I have two granddaughters I feel
like my energy would be better spent
um redirecting more of it towards them
than
um by sibling and my parents and
I think you're on to something and and
I'll say it this way we often
um
we often spend so much energy going back
and trying to edit things that have
happened in our lives if you think of
that like a sentence we try to go back
and edit it edit those sentences as
though we can change them
we can't
the only thing we can do with that PIN
and that paper is to write something new
and if you think about it that way
you've tried for years
to
convince your parents to act your way to
behave your way to lean into these ways
so that your parents won't see you as a
burden and they have chosen not to
you've tried hard to lean in and to do
whatever your brother's asking you to do
and he continues to up the Annie on you
he sends you a bill every month for what
you owe or with because he decided to
care and then he decided the payments
and SSU going back and trying to edit
and trying to edit and try to edit at
some point you can look at that sentence
and say that sentence has been written
with a period at the end of it
and you look at those beautiful
granddaughters
and you think to yourself
I can be a part of writing something new
I can teach them that they are never
going to be a burden
they're always going to be loved no
matter what knucklehead nonsense they
get involved in they're always going to
have a grandma to come home to for as
long as I'm around
now we're writing something completely
new and right now the world doesn't need
any more editing of the past we need
people to sit down come together write
new things into the future
and again it's Gonna Hurt give me a
season of grief and a season of sadness
because the fantasy is going to finally
turn into the vapor that it always was
and then you can be free to look at
those two little girls and say I'm all
in
let's try something new
thank you for your heart
we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we're back as we wrap up
today's show um hey truth be told
Kelly's actually out getting I don't
know why she booked a tattoo for this
early in the morning but she's getting a
giant um
One Republic tattoo
so obnoxious in Old English right across
the middle of her back that's just what
she does um a favorite song off that
record is off the One Republic out of
the One Republic catalog is secrets and
it goes like this
I need another story something to get
off my chest my life gets kind of boring
needs something that I can confess till
all my sleeves are staying red from all
the truth I've said come by it honestly
I swear thought you saw me wink nope
I've been on the brink so
I'm gonna give all my secrets away this
time
don't give all of them away
or maybe to a therapist maybe we'll see
you soon love you